President Trump is urging Republicans to
stick together in his words from a tweet
last night fights this as the White
House tries to recover from an admission
by the president's acting chief of staff
this week that the u.s. did withhold 400
million dollars in US military aid to
Ukraine
the new fuel for impeachment in the
impeachment inquiry comes amid growing
bipartisan criticism of the president's
decision to withdraw US troops from
Syria we too Jiang is at the White House
with more on all of this we do good
morning good morning to you Jeff and
good morning everybody president Trump
insists that he made the right call in
Syria even though backlash is sharp and
continues to grow meanwhile few voices
here at the White House and his in his
own party are sticking up for the
president when it comes to that
impeachment inquiry and finally even
though acting chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney made public remarks this week
he ended up doing much more harm than
good on Friday President Trump quickly
changed the subject when asked to
clarify a stunning admission from his
acting chief of staff and I have news
for everybody get over it
there's going to be political influence
in foreign policy make Mulvaney admitted
there was a quid pro quo involving US
military aid to Ukraine and said the
president froze the money to get Ukraine
to investigate debunked theories about
2016 election meddling we look back to
what happened in 2016 certainly was was
part of the thing that he was worried
about in corruption with that nation and
that is absolutely rolling hours later
Mulvaney reversed his comments in a
statement saying there was absolutely no
quid pro quo President Trump tried to
shift the attention to the Biden family
after Deputy Assistant Secretary of
State George Kent testified he raised
concerns in 2015 about hunter Biden
serving on the board of a Ukrainian gas
company when his father was still the
vice president but those red flags were
ignored
he excoriated the Obama administration
and Joe Biden and Joe Biden's son saying
that has tremendous problems tremendous
problems with Joe Biden's son and the
Ukraine mr. Trump is also punching back
again
fierce criticism over his decision to
pull US troops out of Syria leaving
Kurdish fighters to fend for themselves
against the Turkish military we're doing
very very well with Turkey there's a
ceasefire or a pause or whatever you
want to call it but the Turkish
president has vowed to resume the attack
in three days if the Kurds do not leave
the area by then Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell usually a trump ally
warned of a resurgence of Isis in a
Washington Post op-ed he wrote
withdrawing US forces from Syria is a
grave strategic mistake it will leave
the American people and homeland less
safe in bowden our enemies and weaken
important alliances President Trump says
some European nations have agreed to
take in Isis fighters that were being
detained by the Kurds but so far no
countries have made that announcement
back here at home the president is
dealing with another departure from his
cabinet he announced that Dan brew yet
the number-two in the Energy Department
will take over when secretary Rick Perry
leaves by the end of the year Perry
insists this has nothing to do with his
role in the administration's Ukraine
policy which of course Michelle is at
the center of the impeachment inquiry it
hasn't been a revolving door which a
Jang
thank you